hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
one month ago
dauntless exploded onto the gaming world
following its full release the blend of
hack and slash action composed tactics
modification and awesome behemoth
designs had us all enthralled but just
like many other games which want us to
come back regularly a future plan or a
road map must be in place I've been
looking into the future of dauntless and
oh yes this game has lots in store for
us in the coming weeks months and years
here are 11 new things coming soon to
dauntless so let me know in the comments
which of these is your most anticipated
oh and before I go any further a huge
thank you to dauntless for sponsoring
this video I love you 3000 let's start
with something which actually isn't
coming soon it's because it's already
here if you have PS plus or twitch prime
you have three items and loot waiting
for you right now pause this video and
go get them on the ps4
we have PlayStation themed weapon skins
the ostian steel set model P which comes
in the blue you associate with
PlayStation and if you have Amazon Prime
then indeed you have twitch Prime and
can get your hands on
even more loot right now as I'm writing
this you can pick up a brand new set of
cosmetic armor 2 in game titles a purple
dye supplies and lots of other goodies
too and to link this back to the title
of the video there will be three more
loot drops over the summer on Twitch
prime and judging by the PS plus imagery
we might be getting PlayStation armor in
the future too so free stuff now and in
the coming months get on that and
embrace the fashion element of dauntless
and yes if you're wondering I bought the
renegade dye pack from the star it's
like it's made for me my community are
called the renegades and the core colors
I used our blue and pink I could not
resist
[Music]
this leads to my next point
new cosmetic slots are coming very soon
we will soon be able to apply vanity
items to our head and back the example
given was a halo and wings visually this
will be similar to how back blings work
in fortnight's this will allow us to
look our way embrace our own styles all
I need is a bright pink guitar if you if
you're listening Dauntless masters the
head item seemed like a great idea to
imagine rocking your favorite cap or
something random like devil horns the
more I think about it the more I need
this the only game I can think that has
done headwear very well in the past is
none other than Team Fortress 2 I don't
know about you but I'm prepared to spend
so much platinum on these items to stand
out from the crowd and be unique I'm
gonna be absolutely skint oh and by the
way if you pick up the hunt past or any
items in the store please think about
using code Adam aru as that helps me
create more content based around
dauntless another much-anticipated
update coming soon is to bring the world
to life just a little bit more at
present it sometimes feels like being
placed on a battlefield rather than a
living breathing world but that will
change very soon by now I know you
fought the Boreas one of his unique
traits is to bring in little minion
creatures to fight by his side having
those to worry about and the behemoth
itself makes the battle so interesting
keep that in mind because soon the
entire map will have its own life forms
to watch out for described as slugs who
can interfere with our hunts it's
unclear if they are friend or foe to the
behemoths
you're hunting but they'll most
definitely get in our way I see this as
the first step to witnessing living
worlds with unique creatures in each
biome it may be a little further off
than the word soon but I have faith that
dauntless will continue to build on its
very strong foundations
[Music]
let's move on to combats and how this
will be improved to profound and
expanded upon the first highly notable
improvement is the incoming terror
debuff at present you're likely using
your shock weapons blaze and frost
weapons because of their ability to
apply a status on the behemoth you're
fighting blaze burns the beasts frost
slows them down so what will tara do
well this will be a game-changer terror
debuff will siphon health from the
behemoth taking it from that big bottom
and giving that lovely life force to us
and our crew of misfits essentially
meaning the more we pound on the
behemoth during the debuff the more we
are rewarded with health Tara weapons
will soon become a commodity to hunts so
have a few terror weapons leveled up
ready to take advantage many players are
now reaching the endgame and keeping
those players enthralled is a priority
for the dauntless team one update in
particular looks interesting for you
veterans trials and trials modifiers as
the name suggests trials will be
difficult a real dedication is needed to
fight these behemoths mechanically it's
about smashing behemoth skills together
to make an overpowered behemoth a
difficult to take down so combining
behemoth attributes and modifiers to
change a standard battle into something
legendary in difficulty this activity
will require thought team cohesion and
dedication to overcome the challenge the
example modifier depicts a razor wing
karabakh and crochets vineland shield
and reduced damage to standard attacks
that will definitely create a complex
fight being forced to change our
loadouts and builds utilising mods in
unique ways to overcome that challenge
will be the driving force behind this
game-mode
true endgame content definitely for the
die-hard veterans and of course you know
the vanity rewards will be to die for I
need to man up and get to the endgame as
quick as possible
trials will have its own currency by the
way to rewarded for completing hunts and
there's an add-on to this leaderboards
if you're sick of your mate claiming his
squad is better than yours then it'll be
time to prove it the Slayers who
complete the trials the quickest will
sit higher up on the leaderboard
just
your Latin actor non verba actions speak
louder than words so put your toxic
friend on alert also I'm prepared to be
the guy at the bottom of the leaderboard
I wonder if I can up a weapon skin like
a wooden spoon and to complete your
trials information completing endgame
content like trials will give us access
to lady Luck's store her new shop
opening just off Ramsgate Plaza which
will stock an exclusive assortment of
weapon mods weapon specials cells and
cosmetics oil of cosmetics this proves
that endgame is just the beginning for
dauntless building our ultimate
character with mod specials and of
course those very important vanity items
- I'm sure you'll agree exciting times
ahead so I'm sure you've noticed the
time a PlayStation gamer I'm so embedded
in that ecosystem that it's part of my
channel name but I adore all gaming
platforms if you play on PC fantastic if
you prefer Xbox it's all good but
something coming which could impact us
all went away from our desk or a man
cave of whatever the heck you call your
gaming space both switch and mobile
versions of dauntless are in the works
the switch version is far far far closer
to fruition and the mobile version but
the ability to hunt anywhere you can
muster an Internet signal needs to be
shared
we have cross-platform play and cross
progression too so gaming on the go and
hunting on the go
will be here soon no longer will we miss
those daily hunt past collectibles all
that our off your friends have just to
quickly run a hunt there is no release
date set for the mobile off switch
version but judging by the switch build
at e3 it's pretty damn close on the
switch at least
let's move over to the hunt pass the
current season how are you doing I'm
progressing okay I'm pretty happy I'm
almost through it and some of the vanity
items really do impress me
I come on who doesn't love to do
push-ups like Gaston from Beauty and the
Beast that she didn't think you were
gonna get a Beauty and the Beast
reference anyway the hammer skin in the
hunt past is legit my favorite weapon
skin ever created but what does the
future hold the evolution of the hunt
pass will be known as high skies a
mysterious new figure will arrive in
Ramsgate but let's look at the official
blurb here hi skies delivers a new hunt
pasta Slayers striving for seasonal
glory sail all the way to level 50 to
earn skins for each of your six weapon
types plus a complete set of cosmetic
Corsair armor and just hold on for a
second if you don't speak traditional
English which nobody does anymore you
may think Corsair means a keyboard and
mouse
but alas course as refer to Raiders or
pirates rather and Buccaneers so from
that we can surmise we're gonna be Sky
Pirates oh yeah a champ so down with
that yes please
i legit can't wait to see the weapon
skins oh and by the way why are pirates
called pirates because they are sorry
about that moving on there's a few
smaller updates which can't be talked
about in depth but are certainly worth
your attention firstly a new diable
mouth is on its way the winter harms
grave we have one sentence two teasers
which reads the winter haunts grave is
coming out of hibernation with a new set
of skills and an upgrade for your grave
armor set look for this dire in the
depths of the Maelstrom sounds good
doesn't it the winter haunts grave is
set to arrive in early July so now is
the time to max out your frost armor and
those lays weapons to be prepared for a
bud Game of Thrones impression winter is
coming and one last little tidbit
another minor update which will improve
our quality of life is centered around
the updated loadout screen which will be
updated again very soon will be given
the ability to save entire load outs
easily switching multiple gear and cell
configs which will in turn stream
our approach pre hunt a minor but hugely
impactful update GG devs
so that's where we stand now is a great
time to be a dauntless player and the
future looks bright thanks for watching
I hugely appreciate it and thank you
once again to dauntless for sponsoring
this video right I'm going to play more
dauntless and finish my hunt pass before
the sky pirates arrived I imagine from
PlayStation grenade come over and talk
to me on Twitter please I'm active there
every day it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]